Hi, das ist Podcast, du für Schwinge, jetzt ist Podcast, du für Klinge, jetzt ist Podcast, du für Spinnen, jetzt ist Podcast, du für Beginne, mit Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze. Los geht's. Tietze. Herzlich willkommen. Was? Schön, dass ihr da seid zur neuen Ausgabe. Der Vorhang zieht sich auf, das Spektakel beginnt. Ich grüsse dich, hallo Stefan, Florentin, von weit kam ich her zu dir, Stefan der Schatten Eines Mannes, ein Drache, ein Fahrrad, zwei Vape, keine Hand das war auch frisch. Endlich können wir loslegen. Voll schön, das war fantastisch, das hat mir Spaß gemacht. Ja, absolut, das war richtig schön. Bei solchen Menschen frage ich mich dann immer, wenn ihr so viel Talent habt, warum vergeudet ihr das denn für sowas?
Ja, warum vergeudet ihr sowas, indem ihr einen KI promptet?
So, kommen wir zum ersten Thema. Vor allem, ich hab mich mal, also ich mach mich schon, wenn wir hier unter uns sind, kurz, manchmal lustig über meine Mom, die nicht mehr so richtig schnallt, ähnlich wie deine Nachbarin in der vorvergangenen oder vergangenen Folge, wo du meintest, sie hat den Betrug nicht verstanden, den Paketbetrug an deiner Tür und wollte dir sozusagen helfen, um mit der Betrüger-SMS das Paket dir zu tragen. Man wusste nicht, was hat sie verstanden, was sie nicht verstanden. Offensichtlich hat sie aber nicht den Betrug verstanden, wie er denn ausgeführt wird. Und bei mom ist auch so dass sie manche sachen einfach jetzt akzeptiert also sie gibt sich keine mühe mehr die noch zu verstehen weil sie generationsrechtlich so weit weg ist von den dingen die digital passieren und ich merke das langsam auch wenn du sowas sagst wie ja vielen dank dass es k generiert denke ich mir ja vermutlich ist es das ich hätte es als solches nicht erkannt, ich bin raus, zeige mir wunderschöne Bilder. Was habe ich schon erlebt in meinem Leben, was alles nur KI war, wie viele Interaktionen, wie viele Nachrichten, wie viele Filme habe ich schon gesehen, die einfach nur ein Prompt war, machen Arthouse-Filmen, den Leute mit angeblich gutem Filmgeschmack gut finden würden und Stefan Titzel frisst er aus der Hand. Ja, und ich bin wie dieses Wein, was damals, das sind auch die Referenzen, die ich habe. Ich bin wie dieses Telegramm, das ich damals bekommen habe. Was damals rumging, wie der Kettenbrief. Damals rumging. Und da gab es so einen Wein von so einer Oma, habe ich euch schon mal erzählt, wo dann Jugendliche kommen und so ein Baby hinter ihr holen, der andere reicht sie an und sagt, sie hatten das die ganze Zeit in ihren Haaren. Und die Oma war halt, und der Blick, den diese Oma hatte, die einfach denkt, ja das war es, ich muss beiseite treten, ich muss Platz machen für die Menschen, die jetzt kommen. Sie hatte, Swoiler, kein Baby in den Haaren. Selten hat man das, verfängt sich ein Baby in den Haaren.
Du meinst, weil unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer genauso auch gerade geschaut haben.
Ich fühle mich so wie diese Oma, diese Oma, der ein Baby aus den Haaren geholt wird, die nicht mehr versteht, was passiert. Aber das gibt es ja bei vielen Tieren, dass wenn die merken, sie sind raus, dass sie dann den Hut nehmen. Also dass sie dann wirklich sagen, so, ich nehme den Mantel, ich nehme den Hut, ich bin raus und dann gehen die zum Elefantenfriedhof und legen sich hin und sind tot.
Und der Mensch, glaube ich, hat das tief drin auch noch so ein bisschen, dass sie merken, wenn sie wirklich, okay, gut, ich habe gerade irgendwie, ich finde ja diese Rentner verarschen Nummern immer ganz witzig.
Man hat ein Instagram Reel gesehen, wo jemand mit seiner Oma GTA gespielt hat, GTA 5. Und wenn der Oma gesagt hat, das sind die Nachrichten. Und dann fährt er so ein Auto, überschlägt sie zweimal und fliegt dann in so eine Menschenmenge rein. Und die Oma nur so, oh mein Gott, nein, es wird immer schlimmer. Und es überschlägt sie alles, völlig unrealistisch, aber das finde ich einfach grossartig. Wie mein Opa, der dann uns beim FIFA-Spielen zugeguckt hat und dachte, Borussia Dortmund gewinnt gerade 16 zu 0 gegen die deutsche Nationalmannschaft, basically. Aber ja, das sind diese Momente und die habe ich gerade auch, aber dann einerseits, andererseits finden wir ja auch immer raus, dass AIs, KIs, is tausend in da sind und da muss man auch wieder sagen leute die sich sicher waren und gesagt und die vermeintlich jedes bild was computer generiert ist trennen können von echten bildern sind dann stehen auch doof da und dann sieht sich ein eigenes und sagt am ende stehen wir alle doof da am ende stehen wir alle wie diese oma doof da und gucken mit riesengrossen Augen verwirrt ins Nichts.
Deswegen lachen wir so laut über diese alten Leute, weil wir in ihnen sehen wir uns selbst, wie wir überfordert sind mit der Welt und nicht mehr klarkommen und eigentlich sagen, ich hau ab.
Ich habe zum Beispiel mein Wikipedia-Artikel der Woche. Wollen wir gleich dazu kommen?
Ach so, ich dachte mein Wikipedia-Artikel.
Nein, nein, nein. Gut, die letzten Male war es immer der Wikipedia-Artikel Florentin. Ich dachte, was eine coole Rubrik wäre das denn. Mein Wikipedia-Artikel die Woche. Und mein Wikipedia-Artikel der Woche ist Wahlsturz. Und zwar, wenn Wale sterben, sinken die. Also anders als alle anderen, glaube ich, irgendwie, weil so Wasserleichen und so, die steigen ja auf, keine Ahnung warum. Anders als Menschen, die langsam ins Himmel schweben. Wie Team Rocket. Ja, das war mal wieder ein Schuss in den Oben. Ich weiss nicht, weil meine Oma gestorben ist und dann macht man ja die Fenster auf und dann hebt die Leiche ab und dann fliegt sie in den Himmel. Und das dauert manchmal quälendlang und die ganze Trauergemeinde einfach stundenlang, weil Oma irgendwie so wirklich eine Stunde, einen Meter pro Stunde da hochfliegt. Und Walsturz bedeutet, der Wal schwimmt runter, sinkt auf den Grund des Bodens, auf des Bodensgrund. Auf des Bodensgrundes. Und das ist dann eine komplette Stadt, weil da leben dann Tiere, die können nur in diesen Wahlkadavern leben und sind da unten und brauchen das, weil da unten ist gar nichts, überhaupt nichts, nur dieser Wahlkörper. Und da stürzen sich alle drauf und die brauchen den und leben dann da, leben dann da auch ewig lang davon, bis dann irgendwann mal wieder … Aber ich finde ja Wahlsturz oder steht ja auch oder Wahlfall. Und jetzt hat der was.
Nee, das muss schonahlsturz oder steht ja auch oder wahlfall und hat ja was das muss schon wahlsturz aber es hat ja was wahnsinnig erhabenes ja genau so was wie götterdämmerung genau ich würde gerne den film wahlsturz nennen oder oper warum nicht einfach eine oper ja absolut aber der wahlsturz vor allem die vorstellung auch dass der wahl der würde wahrscheinlich sehr langsam runtersingen, aber dass das so ein Sturz ist von oben. Und für diese Wesen muss ja dieses Wahlding ein gottgleiches Ding sein und denken, was muss das für eine Welt sein, wo die Leben da unten. Warum hat man nicht so ein Findet Nemo, aber so Tone It Down, also wirklich viel weniger Comedy, viel ernster Drama.
Also A24 findet Nemo mit Was sind das für Gestalten, wie oben neben.
Schwarz-Weiss natürlich, unten gibt es keinen.
Viel geraucht, viel geraucht und durch so Algen, die oben so an der Oberfläche kleben,
kommt der Mondschein so mega spitz rein, wie so alten Noir-Filmen, wo es so durch die Lamellen so kam. Komplett auf Tschechisch natürlich. Komplett Tschechisch nur untertitelt. Polnisch untertitelt. Polnisch untertitelt. In Cannes. Und vor allem diese Wesen sind ja winzig klein, das sind ja so kleine Würmchen und Krebse und die denken sich, oben ist eine Welt, wo diese riesigen Leviathane leben und dann muss es doch einen geben, der sagt, fuck it, ich schwimme da hoch, fuck it jetzt mal, fuck it, ich mach's jetzt mal, Leute. Und die anderen so, Carlos, das haben schon vor dir so viele versucht und niemand ist zurückgekehrt, der Ozeangrund riecht nach Versagen und Abstieg. Pawel, alle Geschichten unserer Kultur drehen sich darum, dass wir nicht nach oben ziehen. Wir haben zweihundert verschiedene Geschichten, deren Lektion immer ist, wer zu hoch schwimmt, stürzt. Die Götter da oben schenken uns Wale, sie fallen vom Himmel, das ist unser Futter. Was willst du mehr? Verärgere die Götter nicht! Ich will da hoch, Pavel, ich weiss doch, aber ich muss hochgehen, und ich will unter diesen Leviathan leben! Nepomuk, höre mir zu, gehe nicht! Diesen Sommer, A420 präsentiert, die neueste Comedy von den Machern von K.A.S.2, kommt jetzt zu ihnen Wahlsturz. Und einer muss ja hochfliegen und da würde ich gerne die Geschichte lesen von diesem kleinen Krebs, der sagt, ich gehe hoch. Der kleine Krebs, der hochgeht und dann, wie auch, schwimmt, können Krebs schwimmen oder laufen die, ich weiss nicht, schwimmen die mit ihren Scheren dann unbeholfen und denken sich die ganze Zeit, warum hab ich Scheren? Oh, so hell hab ich Scheren. Nicht fucking flossen. Ja, warum brauch ich Scheren, wo ist Papier? Aber je nachdem. Zwei Hummer, die Schere, die ein Papier spielen. Mein Gott, Leute, der Gag. Ja, damals auf Twitter. Aber jetzt, er heisst, ja, Ex heisst er jetzt. Oder Schere, Schwein, Papier. Okay, ein Hummer-Schwein-Ein Hummer spielt Schere-Schwein-Papier.
Ja, gegen einen?
Perkel.
Als Comic.
Warum gibt es keinen, aber mit Huf, sagt es dann.
Aber können wir bitte mit Huf spielen?
Nein, ohne Huf, aber Ringelschwanz.
Okay, gut.
So, und dann könnt ihr euch.
Der Hummer sieht immer schon, wenn das Schweinchen sich ansetzt, um sich umzudrehen, um Ringelschwanz zu zeigen, kann der Hummer perfekt countern. Mit Papier. Und der Hummer hat Zeitpapier, weil er ein Papierstück in ... Der hat in der Hinter-, in seiner Hotpan, in seiner Hotpan hat er in der Gesäßtasche noch ein Stück Papier, noch so einen alten Kassenzettel, weil er nicht weiß, ob er sein Auto nochmal umtauschen will. Ich weiß nicht, ob man einen Kassenzettel kriegt, wenn man ein Auto kauft. Doch, das ist ein Bon, ein Kassenbon. Aber die sind sehr ganz kurz, weil das ist nur ein Item, das ist nur ein Item. Das sind die ganz kurze, ja, und oft Handgeschrieben. Ja, ja. BMW. Ja, ja. Wie viele Automaten kennst? Hatte ich jetzt aber auch überlegt, weil beim Supermarkt meines Vertrauens war der Pfandautomat kaputt. Man merkt, mein Leben an Spannung und Drama kaum zu überbieten. Das war das Highlight der Woche tatsächlich. Ich finde, dass in dieser Banalität liegt manchmal einfach großer Spaß. Absolut, weil der Pfandautomat ist für mich immer so ein Portal in eine andere Welt. Was passiert da? wohin gehen diese Flaschen, wer holt die ab, wohin kommt das Geld, also hat das was mit einer Bank zu tun, wo kommt das Geld her, staatlich wahrscheinlich subventioniert, nehme ich mal an. Nehmen wir mal an. Aber wie das genau funktioniert, weiss niemand. Und dann ist es immer so, wenn dann dieses Portal kaputt ist und nicht mehr funktioniert und dann stockt da was oder geht es nicht mehr weiter und dann geht diese Klappe auf und dann hast du die inneren Matrixkabel, die da rausgucken und dann geht das nicht mehr. Und dann stand halt so ein gelangweilter Mitarbeiter da, dem man die Flaschen gegeben hat, und dann hat der händisch auf dem Zettel geschrieben, was dein Pfandwert ist.
Da dachte ich, komm, pack noch ein paar Nullen ran. Das ist dein Tag. Das ist dein Tag. Mach doch aus den zwei Euro 20 Millionen Euro. Das ist deine Chance. Aber das ist glaube ich Inflation. Also ich glaube, das ist Inflation. Das kann sein. Du meinst, ich bin dann selbst persönlich dafür verantwortlich, wenn Edeka einfach 20 Millionen aushändigen muss. Genau, der junge Mann kann ja sozusagen Geld erfinden. Und das ist genau, liebe Kinder da draußen, Inflation. Genau, deswegen sind eure Eltern zu arm, um mit euch nach Disney World zu fliegen. Deswegen werdet ihr euch niemals eine Wohnung in München leisten können. Ich meine, da stand dann drauf, da stand vor allem nicht drauf, wie viele Flaschen, da stand nur der Betrag drauf und die Unterschrift des Mitarbeiters als als Bürgschaftsiegel, als Siegel, wo ich mir dachte, okay, das ist noch so wirklich Vertrauen, da weiss man, ja, nur er kann so unterschreiben. Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich da jetzt wirklich noch so viele Nullen hinzufüge, dass da 20 Millionen steht und dann an der Kasse so, Jonas, kommst du mal?
Bringst du mal Wechselgeld? Dennis, bringst du mal Wechselgeld, danke.
Hätten die mir 20 Millionen auszahlen müssen?
Ich hab's nur noch in Münzen. Kann ich jetzt in Münzen auszahlen?
Ist okay, ist in Ordnung.
Da kommt so ein Lkw. Pippiep, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, ppp, p. Weil ich denke dann, weil irgendwie das System ist so für uns gemacht. wir haben damit nicht so wahnsinnig viel Pfand.
Und wenn es eklig viel wird, bringt man das weg.
Und dann bringt man das weg, dann steckt man es da rein und man ist das Problemlos. Aber wenn das irgendwie nicht geht, dann habe ich so ekle Gedanken von, alle bringen so viel Pfand hierher. Wenn dieser Automat jetzt hier dicht macht, dann war es das. Das staut sich. Auch wenn man so mal am Wertstoffhof oder so ist und mal irgendwie Möbel entsorgen muss, Alte oder sowas.
War jetzt häufiger, weil mein Elternhaus ja nicht mehr existiert, habe ich da alles da einmal hingebracht, viel Kram, den man nicht mehr loswerden konnte. Und das ist so krass, weil das machten ja nicht nur wir an diesem Tag, sondern 90 andere Menschen, die an dem gleichen Augenblick, wo wir da sind, auch da sind und Müll wegwerfen. Und das machen ja alle Menschen immer, alle immer so wütend. Weil alle haben dieses konnte ich nicht bei Ebay verkaufen Gesicht. Ja, genau. Dieses, es ist ja nichts mehr wert. Steht schon seit fünf Wochen bei auf Ebay Kleinanzeigen und jetzt, jetzt kommt's weg. Ist so spannend, diese Ebay Kleinanzeigenwelt, die ich jetzt auch kennengelernt habe, weil das gute Bone-China-Geschirr meiner Grossmutter. Aus Knochen oder was? Aus wirklich Knochen, ja. Von welchem Wesen? Ja, das ist super spannend. Also Bone, das ist mein Wikipedia-Artikel der Woche, weil Bone-China ist so angeblich das wertvollste Porzellan, weil das so wahnsinnig leicht ist, aber so wahnsinnig stabil. Das Knochenporzellan mit einer sehr hohen Kantenschlagfestigkeit, eine grosse KSF. Das braucht man ja, wenn man da seinen Apfelstrudel drauf verzehrt. Genau, richtig. Dann sagt man, oh, zum Glück ist die Kantenschlagfestigkeit hoch. Wenn die Kantenschlagfestigkeit nicht so hoch wäre, würde ich hier nicht so gerne von essen. Und dann plötzlich, obwohl es um so schönes Gehabetes Geschirr geht, reden dann wie so Männer, die über Autos reden, so, was heißt das für eine KSF, na, 1400. Hui, da war es mit Schass, ich habe mich nicht klumpen lassen, du. Ne, da habe ich mir mal richtig zugeschlagen. Sehr weiss und durchscheint, genau, man kann es hochhalten, Licht scheint durch, das ist auch ein Qualitätsmerkmal, gilt als das Beste in Ilse Porzellan. War also mal was wert? Hat meine Mutter zu meiner Kommunion bekommen? Viele Fragen, viele Fragen allein da schon zu. Religion. Genau. Und dann war das Lackes halt rum und dann habe ich so ähnliches Porzellan gefunden bei Ebay und dachte, ja, jetzt sind wir reich. Weil da hat so eine Frau sehr klar aufgelistet, wie sie ihr Set, ihr Service verkauft und was wert ist. Und dann habe ich sozusagen diese werte genommen und auf unser porcelain wert das war ein grosses set angewandt und ja es hat das eingestellt für sehr viel geld und dann kam niemand und habe ich das für weniger geld reingestellt aber auch niemand war interessiert irgendwann habe ich das ohne scheiss für fuffi reingestellt niemand war interessiert ich habe zu verschenken eingestellt niemand interessiert es war wirklich es war für niemanden bewegt dann kam so ein sozialkaufhaus hat geguckt was kann man aus der wohnung von dingen die wir nicht mehr verkaufen konnten oder verschenken wollten noch nehmen die wollten das auch nicht haben und dann am ende stand ich dann da mit diesem beutel bone china ja dafür mussten wir irgendwelche wesen sterben ja anscheinend was ist denn für knochen weiß ich nicht knochen posten wahrscheinlich irgendwelche tiere wissen wir nicht aber und dann stehst du dann mit diesem grossen karton mit bone china den wikipitartikel im kopf im Ohr noch irgendwie das und Edelste Porzellan und dann stehe ich da an dem Wertstoffhof, Wertstoffhof und hab wirklich alle Teller einzeln in diesen Müllcontainer geworfen. Und die gehen auch nicht mehr kaputt, weil die nur hohe Handenschlagkraft haben. Die Kantenschlagfestigkeit ist so hoch. Du kannst nicht mal einen Tellersturz machen und die genüsslich einzeln zerdeppern.
Wir haben keinen Tellersturz, Pavel.
Und dann jeglich in der Namen, alle haben diesen Blick, wie ich den da hatte, hatten den so drauf.
Alle, die da stehen und wütend, weil niemand hat Grund, wütend zu sein, weil alle stehen da und bringen Müll weg.
Naja gut, dieser Tag ist das Ende von einer wochenlangen Leidensgeschichte, wo man Stück für Stück seine Ansprüche runtergeschraubt hat und jede Woche aufs Neue gemerkt hat, nee, es ist noch schlimmer. Es ist noch schlimmer, es geht noch tiefer. Ich bin noch weniger wert einfach. Nichts davon. Und dann stehen da alle und werfen wütend die Sachen da runter. Das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, aber ja. Man wirft nie was in den Pfandautomaten rein, also so als Zimmerwerfen. Kann man nicht. Kann man kaum, das ist wirklich nicht so leicht. Weil man es reinschieben muss. Man muss es schon reinschieben, aber es glaube ich würde grossen Spaß machen, wenn man das machen würde. Meine Frage, meine Frage. Halt, Lars. Du legst es doch rein und dann lässt es doch nicht einfach nur reinfallen. Nein! Sondern du gibst ihm doch noch so einen richtigen Puff.
Ja, sehr klar!
Ja, oder?
Ich glaube, daran kann man feststellen, wie jung und knackig und lebensfroh man ist, wie viel Kraft man noch der Flasche gibt, wenn man sie in ... Vor allem, ich denke mir sogar immer, ich tue ja dem System was Gutes, weil die zerdepperte Flasche nimmt weniger Raum ein als die ganze Flasche.
In so einen Container passen vielleicht tausend ganze, aber locker 20 Millionen zerdepperte Flasche nimmt weniger Raum ein als die ganze Flasche. In so einen Container passen vielleicht tausend ganze, aber locker 20 Millionen zerdepperte Flaschen rein. Also bin ich der Depp, wenn der Depp ist, wer nicht zerdeppert. Der Depp ist, wer nicht zerdeppert. Schreib das mal gerne da drauf, um da Platz zu sparen. Am Ende wird das hier eher eingesch... Eingesch... Eingesch... Genau, eingesch... Eingesch... Eingesch... Eingesch, und dann wieder die Farben ausgelegt, damit die, und dann wieder Dichtigkeit reingeht. Und dann wird das alles zu einem grossen Schlamassel, genau, wieder aufgeblasen, die Glastinnen und... Aber dass ihr mir aufpasst mit der Hitze. Ja, übertreibt's nicht bitte. Nein, damit's neu benutzt. An alle Glasbläser da draußen, übertreibt's nicht. Damit's dann wieder in unseren Händen ist. Genau, damit wir davon wieder näheren sorgen können. Das ist der Kreislauf des Glases. Ja, und ich finde es wunderschön. Es ist wunderschön, dass die Natur das so eingerenkt hat, soekugelt hat wie ich richtig gut aber das ist auch so ein ratschlag es gibt ein paar ratschläge die man immer benutzen kann die immer nutzlos sind übertreibst nicht okay ich war kurz davor es zu übertreiben ich war jetzt wirklich gut dass du sagst ich war jetzt wirklich kurz davor es zu übertreiben ich würde sagen übertreibst nicht danke danke weil ich war wirklich sekunden Sek wirklich kurz davor, es zu übertreiben. Nee, ich würde nur sagen, übertreib es nicht. Nee, danke, danke, weil ich war wirklich Sekunden, Sekunden davon entfernt, es zu übertreiben, und dein Rat hat mich nochmal dazu gebracht, es dann doch nicht zu übertreiben. Ja. Ich weiß, du willst jetzt viel Sport machen, aber übertreib es nicht. Okay, gut. Ich weiß, du willst weniger essen und so, aber übertreib es nicht. Alles klar, werde ich nicht. Aber ist das, sagt man das so, beginnt es häufig, übertreib's nicht? Ich glaube schon. Weil du jemanden bist vielleicht, der es eher übertreibt. generell eher ins Extrem treibt, ja. Der Herr sagt so, übertreib's nicht. Obwohl manchmal würde ich mir wünschen, es weniger als zu übertreiben. Ich hab zum Beispiel gemerkt, dass immer wenn ich meinen Pulli ausziehe, ziehe ich auch mein T-Shirt aus. Nicht übertreiben. Also, und da denke ich mir selbst, ich stehe dann nackt da und denke mir, das ist übertrieben. Ich weiss nicht, was das ist. Ich liebe das, es gibt Kumpels, die halten sich dann die Shirts fest. Und ich finde das so eine süße, süße Geste. Die halten sich die Shirts fest, wenn man den Pulli auszieht. Ich finde, zwei Sachen finde ich ganz toll in so Männerfreundschaften.
Und das eine ist, der eine zieht sich den Hoodie aus und der andere hält das Shirt fest, damit es nicht entblößt. Finde ich super süss. Das andere ist, wenn beide auf dem Roller fahren und der Händere sich umarmt. Weil das ist so immer noch, even today, ist es ja so, dass in Männerfreundschaften selten so eine wirkliche Zunängung gezeigt wird. Ja, absolut. Und dann macht der Fahrer so einen Geschwenker und der Hinterher so, oh, Vorsicht, oh, kurz Panik, aber dann geht es wieder über in so eine ganz zarte Angeschmied. Und das ist der einzige Moment, wo sich so typische, die immer noch sozusagen, ja, oldschool Männer umarmen. Ja, ich mag das auch in Männerfreundschaften, wenn man sich gegenseitig so den Schritt haut. Ja, oder so richtig reinfasst. So minutenlang massiert. Ja, genau. Weil man hat ja oft auch, also ich finde das gut, aber das stimmt schon. Aber ist es nicht so, weil als du jetzt Männer gesagt hast, habe ich automatisch an so Pumper Bros gedacht. Ja, an die denke ich ja auch gerade. Und da dachte ich mir so, dass man nicht sagt so, weil ich denke immer so, Bodybuilder investieren wahnsinnig viel Zeit in den Körper, können den oft aber gar nicht sozialkonform zeigen. So, du kannst nur eine bestimmte Anzahl an Stunden im Schwimmbad verbringen oder in der Sauna.
Aber glaub mal, du kannst sehr viele Stunden bei TikTok verbringen ohne Shirt. So, und dann denkst du dir, okay, jetzt zieh mal den Pulli aus und zieh halt mal, oh, jetzt zieht man meine Sixpack.
Und dann kommt der Kumpel und hält dein T-Shirt fest.
Und jetzt aber, und dann so, und dann so, und dann so als Pumper-Bro bist du in so einem Moment, ich finde das eine ganz tolle Geste.
Du, Tobi, ich mach mal die Tür zu. Du, ich fand es eine super tolle Geste, dass du mein T-Shirt festgehalten hast. Ja, wenn du dich nicht immer entlösen musst. Super nett, super nett. Mach mal ja nicht so gern. Rutsch einfach mit hoch, kann ja immer passieren. Man hat das auch nicht in der Kontrolle, weil man muss so viel Energie investieren, um den Pullover überhaupt zu greifen. Ich mache noch kurz die andere Tür zu, okay? Bitte. Nur dass du es weisst, ich habe da gar nichts dagegen eigentlich, dass wenn man mal so, wenn das T-Shirt mal so kurz hochgeht und so, weil du weisst ja, ich habe jetzt, ich gehe viel trainieren und so und dann ist es gar nicht so, also du musst gar nicht, ich finde die Geste toll, du kannst es bei jedem anderen auch machen, aber bei mir vielleicht einfach. Aber willst du es, okay, das habe ich ganz. Oder das lässt dich dann natürlich im schlechten Licht darstellen, weil die Leute denken, Herr, warum hält der mich zieht. Das ist mir unangenehm, weil dann ist es komische Freund. Okay, du hast recht, nee, sorry, ich will dir jetzt auch dir nicht die Geste verwehren, damit Leute nicht denken, wir hätten keine enge, weil ich finde, wir haben eine sehr enge Beziehung. Wir fassen uns gerne in den Schritt. Ich finde das klasse. Voll, ich auch. Ich liebe es vor allem, wenn du Roller fährst und ich mal wieder mein Fahrrad vergessen habe. Willst du nicht vielleicht einfach, du kannst ja dann so hinschnellen so zum T-Shirt. Aber bist du langsam. Ich fall hin. Ich fall furcht hin, du stolperst. Super. Aaaaaah! Und dann stolperst du und dann kriegst du ihn hin und dann kannst du ja zu mir eilen und das dann noch mal runterziehen, aber jeder hat's gesehen. Jeder hat's bereits gesehen. Und sogar noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit, weil ich so auffällig hingefallen bin. Richtig. Jeder hat's gesehen. Und vielleicht kann mir beim Hinfallen das Shirt so wegrutschen. Ah, was ich kann. Vielleicht können wir die Aufmerksamkeit eher auf meinem Oberkörper. Oder meinst du das als Vergleich, das ist dann im Kontrast? Ja, ich kann mehr essen oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mich gehen lassen ein bisschen, damit du besser wirkst oder so. Ich liebe unsere sehr gesunde Freundschaft, die nicht irgendwie komisch, die ist voll auf Augenhöhe und cool. Mein T-Shirt oben, du liegst am Boden, dein T-Shirt oben. Genau. Du rennst zu mir, hast dein T-Shirt weiterhin oben, dein Bauch schwabbelt links und rechts. Auch Dinge, die nicht vorteilhaft aussehen. Wenn du vielleicht nicht duscht oder so. Ja, klar. Für die Rollersituation war das vielleicht auch. Also ich finde, du hast einen tollen Geschmack in Parfüm und so. Geschmack? Ah. Ja, aber ich finde, also ich muss sagen, dein ureigener Körpergeruch hat was sehr männlich, herbes, angenehmes, finde ich auch tatsächlich.
Ah, okay. Ey, weißt du, ich finde es total toll, was wir haben. Wir haben, was andere Männer nicht haben.
Ich finde es super.
Es ist richtig super.
Wollen wir die Türen wieder aufmachen?
Wir machen alle Türen auf.
Alles klar.
And then they came out of the closet. What? Naja, also bei mir ist es natürlich ein bisschen blöd, aber ich weiss nicht, vielleicht habe ich auch die falsche Technik beim Pulli ausziehen, weil man … Ich würde das halten, dein Shirt für dich. Ja? Ja. Aber du stehst leider oft sehr weit weg von mir. Ich bin sehr weit weg, ja, ja. Du stehst sehr weit weg von mir, wenn ich mich umziehe. Soll ich dann extra noch mal... Ich stehe meistens an der Wand und habe meine Augen zu. La la la la! Soll ich dann extra näher zu dir hingehen, kurz bevor ich meinen Pulli ausziehe oder nicht? Du sag einfach, hey Stefan, ich will meinen Pulli ausziehen. Sagst in dieser Reihenfolge, hey Stefan, ich möchte gerne meinen Pulli ausziehen. Okay. Dann weiss ich oft schon, was zu tun. Dann würde ich dir helfen, dein Shirt festzuhalten. Das finde ich eine süße Geste, ich mag das sehr, wenn Leute das machen, aber weil es ist ganz normal, Florantin, mach dir da keine Sorgen, lass es dir von mir sagen, jemand, der oft seine Pullis auszieht in der Öffentlichkeit, es ist furchtbar, es ist absolut furchtbar, und man zieht immer sein Shirt mit aus. Es sei denn, man schwitzt richtig doll und das Shirt pappt so an einem im Sommer,
dann geht das Shirt, dann geht der Pulli oft weg. Aber hat man auch oft kein Pulli ab,
muss man dazu auch mal sagen.
Also wenn diese kurzen
magischen Momente, wo es warm genug ist,
verschweißt, aber auch noch nicht
zu warm, dass man keinen Pulli trägt.
Diese herrlichen Momente, so
im Mittfrühjahr,
April, Anfang Mai.
Kennen wir ja diese ersten Date-Momente, was ist deine Lieblingsjahreszeit? Ja genau, dieser Sweetspot, an dem man so doll schwitzt, dass das Shirt an einem pappt, aber man auch noch Pullis trägt. Wenn man den Pulli austrägt, das Shirt nicht mit hochzieht. Hättest du Lust, mich nochmal zu sehen? Nein, ehrlich gesagt. Oder wenn man einen Pulli trägt und eine Jacke anzieht, dann passiert es oft, dass die Pulliärmel dann so eingerollt werden und nicht rauskommen. Klar, jetzt sagt ihr, man kann natürlich mit den Händen so die Pulliarme festhalten, das schränkt einen natürlich aber wieder in der Beweglichkeit ein. Also auch da, vielleicht könnte ein Bro in die Jackenärmel reingreifen und den Ärmel von innen festhalten und rausziehen. Ja, finde ich super. Und dann könnte man da was machen. Oder beim Anzug zum Beispiel. Im Anzug ist es ganz wichtig, dass die Ärmel des Hemms rausgucken, rausrotzen. Und dann ist es natürlich auch gut, in dem man reingreift. Genau, also greift euch mal häufiger in die Kleidung rein. Helft euch gerne mal beim Anziehen, so ist es gar nicht so leicht. Das ist ein Kinder-Erwachsenen-Ding. Ja, ja. So, ich würde auch mal gerne im Erwachsenenalter mit einem Schnürsenkel gebunden bekommen. Ja, oder so ein Ritter-Knappen-Ding. Es war ganz normal, dass die Knappen dem Ritter helfen, die Rüstung anzulegen und hinten zuzuschnüren. Und im alten Rom war es auch ganz normal, dass man mal was mit Männern mal hatte. Ja, absolut. Ja. Und dass man da einfach sagt, hey, das kannst du... oder Zofentum. So. Das Zofentum, dass man da mal wieder sagt, das Kleid hinten zu oder so. Ja, kein Problem. Nee, genau. Ich finde das klasse. Ich finde das richtig klasse. Helft euch beim An- und Ausziehen. Richtig. Finde ich richtig super. Nee, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass jetzt die Zeit vorbei ist, wo man drei, weil du hast ja gerade angesprochen, es gibt ja eine Zeit im Jahr, Winter, wo man ein Shirt, mal im Winter so Unterhemd, Shirt, Pulli, Jacke anhat. Wieso, das ist unsere Idee. Tiere haben dann einfach Winterfell, kriegen sie. Und wir ziehen uns vier verschiedene Schichten an. Wie bescheuert sind wir eigentlich? Warum nicht eine dicke? Warum nicht eine richtig dicke Schicht? Warum hat man nicht einfach den Schrank voller T-Shirts mit zunehmender Dicke? Exakt genau, das meine ich. Einfach wirklich ein ein Zentimeter dickes T-Shirt, das dann auch aber lange Ärmel hat und vielleicht auch so ein Kopfding und das einfach anziehen. Wir haben so viel Kram in verschiedenen Dicken, ich will richtig dicke Dicken und dann weniger Kram davon. Absolut und du hast eigentlich so wie bei Art Simpson das ganze Jahr aber jeden Tag das exakt gleiche T-Shirt an, nur ist es halt dicker und dünner, je nach Situation, und kannst dann halt anpassen, aber du siehst
exakt gleich aus jeden Tag. Wie Wintersommerreifen. Ja. Wie so ein Wintershirt, so ein dickes Shirt. Ich habe mir
Sandalen jetzt bestellt, weil ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Socken, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Schuhe anziehen,
ich will eigentlich, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Körperkrümmung, so dieses Runterbeugen, so mein ich nicht mehr. Keine Körperkrümmung, bist du erst in den KKK gegründet. Ja, genau, keine Körperkrümmung Köln, KKK und der Verein, aktuell noch nicht viele Mitglieder, null Mitglieder, ich bin selber ausgeträchtigt, ich bin kurz nach nach der Gründung wieder ausgeträcht. Aus steuerrechtlichen Gründen? Das hat er alles steuerrechtliche Gründe. Und deswegen habe ich keinen Bock mehr, deswegen habe ich mir schön Sandalen bestellt. Und ich sage mal so, die haben ein bisschen auf sie warten lassen. Ja, da war Doktor Amazon, Jeffrey, Jeffrey hat da wieder so ein bisschen schludern lassen. Und dann ist was ganz Merkwürdiges passiert. Und das ist wirklich so, das klingt jetzt dumm und quatschig und vielleicht werden es mir Leute nicht glauben, aber es ist wirklich hundertprozentig so passiert. Und zwar, ich dachte mir so, ah, habe ich nicht vor ein paar Tagen die Sandalen bestellt, so, was ist mit den Sandalen, warum dauert das denn so lange, ich dachte, das müsste eigentlich schon da sein, und dann habe ich wirklich laut in den Raum gesagt, wo sind die Sandalen bestellt, so was ist mit den Sandalen, warum dauert das denn so lange, ich dachte, das müsste eigentlich schon da sein und dann habe ich wirklich laut in den Raum gesagt, wo sind meine Sandalen und plötzlich klingelt es an der Tür. In dem Moment, wo du laut sagst, wo sind denn meine Sandalen? Moment, es klingelt an der Tür. Du hast allein in deiner Wohnung gesagt, wo sind denn meine Sandalen? Es klingelt an der Tür, die Tür geht auf, ah ja, hier die Lieferung. Ah ja, hier die Lieferung, als wäre er erinnert worden durch seinen Ruf. Ja, und ich stehe seit Tagen im Treppenhaus. Was wollte ich denn nochmal hier machen? Warte mal. Wo sind denn meine Sandalen? Ah, Ding Dong.
Und erst dachte ich mir, ah okay, es sind nicht die Sandalen, weil Sandalen werden ja in so einem Schulkarton geliefert. Das wäre jetzt echt ein bisschen verrückt gewesen. Es war eher so diese braune, labbrige Tüte. Ja. Da dachte ich, da sind eher T-Shirts, Unterhosen, Socken sowas drin. Mach die auf, Sandalen. Aber bist du fürs klassische Modell Birkenstock gegangen? Äh, nein, weil ich besitze schon Birkenstocks, allerdings in Köln, und deswegen dachte ich mir so, du kannst keine zwei Lamborghinis haben. Wenn du einen hast, dann brauchst du danach noch so einen Alltagsaufbau.
Das ist wie eine Swatch, also wie die Second Watch.
Zwar die Idee von Swatch, dass alle Leute in der Schweiz eine krasse Uhr haben, die haben dann die Omegas schaffhausen die rolex die tagheuer ein wieder zurück die üblo zwei zu viel die ja so viel you name it rolex habe ich glaube ich gesagt aber und dann die sind halt sehr teuer aber man geht ja mal schwimmen. Oder man geht ja mal fechten. Oder man geht ja mal Polo spielen. Oder man geht ja mal Golf spielen. Da merkt man wieder, dass du vom Fechten so gar keine Ahnung hast. Oh, trägt der eine Uhr beim Fechten? Naja, aber du kannst doch wissen, wie du es jetzt beim Fechten. Du kannst doch, du kannst doch beim Fechten keine Armbanduhr tragen. Sorry, ich möchte Degen, Degen fechten, meinte ich. Ja, da kannst du keine Armbanduhr tragen. Da sticht der andere dir da ins Handgelenk rein und hängt da fest. Nee, über dem Anzug. Über dem Anzug. Und nach jedem Punkt guckst du auf die Uhr. Das ist gegen den Ehrenkodex, der Fecht. Wann ist das endlich vorbei? Wann werde ich endlich nicht mehr gestochen von diesen Menschen? Vorschlag? FC Bundesliga? Bitte, bitte, bitte. Die Fussball-Bundesliga? Und alle tragen Abwanduhren. Man guckt einfach mal, wie sich das Spiel verändert. Weil für mich, ich finde, die Bundesliga ist langweilig geworden. Die Bundesliga tritt auf der Stelle seit Jahren. Jetzt ist es doch gerade super spannend geworden, weil noch Bayer Leverkusen Meister geworden ist. Seit Jahren auf der Stelle. Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, einfach mal Curveballs, einfach mal irgendwas reinwerfen und gucken, was passiert. Jeder trägt zwei Armbanduhr. Mehr Curveballs im Fussball, möchtest du gerne. Jeder Spieler hat zwei Armbanduhren. Damit haben wir insgesamt vierundsvierzig Armanduhren.
Und ab einer gewissen Menge
Armanduhren sollte man das Ticken hören, oder?
Wenn die genau
gleichzeitig eingestellt ist, was ein komischer Vorschlag
jetzt wäre, dann
natürlich haben die die gleiche Zeit.
Die gleiche Zeit, aber doch nicht die gleiche Sekundenzeit.
Und bei dem einen
ist es locker fünf mal. Aber wäre das nicht ein geiler
Marketing-Gag, so von
einer deiner Uhrenmarken?
Vielen Dank. Zeit, aber doch nicht die, glaube ich, Sekundenzeit. Und bei dem einen ist locker fünf mal. Aber wäre das nicht ein geiler Marketing-Gag, so von einer deiner Uhrenmarken?
Ja, um eine zu nennen. Um eine zu nennen, nenn mal einen.
Zum Beispiel, ähm, Wilkinson, Philipp, ähm, wie hielt es, Patek Philipp, Patek Philipp.
Dass die mal sagen, pass auf, FC Bundesliga, das Endspiel, das grosse Spiel, Leipzig gegen Rostock, Clash of the Titans und wir sponsern das Spiel und zwar kriegt jeder am Eingang eine Uhr und dann hast du so ein Stadion mit seinen 50.000 Leuten plus 44 auf dem Felde, hast du 55end Uhren, die alle ... Und das müsste man ja hören. Und dann beweisen die nicht nur, dass ihre Uhren alle perfekt präzise sind, sondern auch laut, sondern auch fucking laut. Das ist ein Qualitätsmerkmal, das will man ja bewerben, sondern auch unfassbar laut. Und dann sagt man so, okay Leute, Halbzeit. Ah, die muss man pfeifen. Ende Sekunde da, Torwart, bleibt noch mal eine Sekunde da. Da müssen alle mal ruhig sein, ob man es hört oder nicht. Das einzige, was wir bräuchten, wären halt 55.000 eurer Uhren. Ja okay, kein Problem, wann würde sie morgen haben? Morgen, ja, ja. Morgen ist das Endspiel. Und daher kommt die nämlich, die Second Watch. Das ist ja genial. Die Second Watch war die Idee. Oh, das ist so gutes Partywissen, ey. Das ist so super. Die Second Watch ist Swatch. Wenn ihr auf einer Party jemanden trefft, der eine Swatch trägt, ihr habt diese Geschichte im Kopf. Meinst du nicht, dass die Swatch-Fergen das nicht? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Okay, alles klar. Und ich glaube, das ist ein guter Icebreaker. Ja. Weil Leute werden gerne, glaube ich, auf ihre Uhr angesprochen, weil Uhr... wer keine gute Uhr hat, trägt, hat keine Uhr. Ja, du hast ja so deine Schlappen, deine Second Schlappen. Ja. Deine Schlappen. Deine Spirkenstocks. Ja, die Spirkenstocks, die Second Birkenstocks. Nee, da will ich nicht darauf angesprochen werden, bitte. Weil jeder muss Schuhe tragen. Wie, worauf willst du dich angesprochen werden? Also, es gibt Modeobjekte, die trägt jeder, und dann gibt es optionale Modeobjekte. Und Schuhe muss jeder Mensch tragen. Das heisst, nicht jeder Mensch mag seine Schuhe oder verbindet was Besonderes mit seinen Schuhen. Du möchtest nicht auf die notwendigen Dinge angesprochen werden. Ich würde, wenn, dann immer nur, ach wie schöne Ohrringe, ach was für ein schönes Nasenpiercing, was für ein schöner Haarreif, weil das sind Dinge, die nicht notwendigerweise, die müsste man nicht tragen. Was für ein schönes Diadem, was für ein herrlicher Turban, was für eine schöne Krone, was für ein schönes Cape, das sind Dinge, die muss man nicht tragen und deswegen wird die Person was damit verbinden. Je nach Wetter-Situation finde ich Cape nicht schlecht.
Essentiell für dich?
Regen-Cape.
Aber du meinst jetzt das, was komplett rumgeht, oder was? Nee, wenn der Wind von hinten kommt und der Regen dir nur so auf den Rücken schäppert, willst du doch so einen Cape von hinten. Aber was machst du, wenn du gegen den Regen gehen musst? noch die beste Seinfeld-Folge der Welt, wo er in diesem Typ im Cape stand, Larry David,
als er sich gefragt hat haben was ist das für ein kerl warum trägt man cape aber es ist ja wirklich superheldenfilme kam ja daher dass es ja mal irgendwann ein kleidungsstück war wahrscheinlich zu sagen auch der zorro trägt ja auch ein keil ja klar ritterarm auch ein cape getragen ich glaube Das hat was mit Reiten zu tun, weil Sankt, äh, Sankt... Stefan, ja, Sachs, Sankt Martin.
Sankt Martin äh, Sankt...
Stefan, ja, Sachs, Sankt Martin. Sankt Martin, der hatte doch auch, ja, Umhang ist dann wieder so ein Ding, ne? Eigentlich, weil man sagt ja, Sankt Martin teilt seinen Umhang, aber eigentlich war es ja ein Cape, das also schon ein Gehe... die Hälfte eines Kleidungsstücks, weil es ja nur so ein Hintergeber war und endlich viertelt er das. Also er schneidet, die minimalste Sache, die man einem halbiert geben kann, gibt er einem dann. Aber wenn ich Reiter werbe, ich würde auch sowas von fucking Umhang tragen, weil wie cool ist das denn, wenn der umhang so hinter die Heer flattert. Ich meine, du darfst dann kein Schild, kein Köcher, nichts auf dem Rücken tragen oder du trägst drüber. Das verstehe ich bei Motorradfahrern oder Rollerfahrern. Ja, tragt Capes! Fucking Cape! Tragt Capes? Ja! Ja, oder die Tour de France. Wird doch mal ein ganz anderes Ereignis, wenn die alle fucking lange Capes tragen und sich dann, weil die haben doch eh schon diese Kolonnen. Wenn die trampeln. Dann können die sich doch einfach festhalten am Cape des Vordermanns. Oder? Ja, aber es ist eine Trampelsportart. Und Trampeln ist uncool. Für ein bisschen. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. Ich weiss, viele radeln gerade, Megatrend, Rennrad, aber man trampelt. Im Kern trampelt man. Es ist ein Trampeln, ja. Es ist ein wütendes Trampeln. Genau, und das Coole, was zum Beispiel, finde ich, Motorräder haben und halt Reiten, ist dieses erhabene, jemand macht etwas für mich.
Etwas anderes leistet gerade viel.
Genau.
Und es hat natürlich etwas Erhabenes, wenn man nicht selber trampelt.
Natürlich sollte man eher Fahrrad fahren als Motorrad, ist gar keine Frage.
Aber Capes und Fahrrad finde ich ein bisschen, vor allem das kann sich auch in Schweichen verheller.
Und der Schweiss.
Und der Schweiss?
Der Schweiss, ja. Der Rücken ist schweissanfällig.
Und dann hast du das alles im Cape drin, das ist auch nicht gut, das stimmt schon, ja. Ja, ne, ich finde, aber machen wir immer mehr Capes beim Motorradfahren, habe ich selten gesehen, finde ich richtig geil, so Batman-mäßig. Das ist schon cool. Das sind ja iconic Bilder von, die uns Christopher Nolan da auf die Leinwand gezaubert hat. Ja, gepinselt quasi. Die uns Christopher Nolan da auf die Leinwand gepinselt hat, ne? Aber ja, aber ich glaube, ich würde dann eher so einen Cape mit einer Sollbruchstelle machen. Also mit so einer gepunkteten Linie so am Hals, dass wenn der Cape sich irgendwo verhängt, dass es einfach so abgerissen wird wie so ein Kinoticket. Ja, genau, super. Und man dann noch so einen ganz erbärmlichen Stummel-Uhrang hat und nicht davon dann einfach weggerissen wird und einfach komplett stirbt. So, das wäre natürlich auch blöd. Mehr Sollbruchstellen. Generell, Sollbruchstellen. Ich liebe Sollbruchstellen. Ja, absolut. Du brauchst viel mehr Sollbruchstellen. So, und dann kam es diese Woche zu einer komischen Situation, muss ich dir kurz erzählen, weil, wie gesagt, ich bin gerade in so einem Ebay-Tunnel. So, und jetzt, wie erzähle ich das, dass wir als Familie nicht wie die grössten Vollidioten rüberkommen? Aber mein Vater hatte eine, so eine Luftdrucksportpistole. Und ich weiss nicht, woher er die genau hatte, aber es war manchmal ganz lustig, sich in den Keller zu stellen, da hatten wir so so Papierzielscheiben und er war nie in so einem Sportschützenverein, ich glaube, sein Bruder hat ihm das mal irgendwann gegeben. Und dann hatte man so Papierzielscheiben und dann konnte man sich in die andere Ecke des Kellers stellen und darauf schiessen. Und du hast dann so kleine Diabolos da reingemacht, so kleine, ich weiß nicht, auf welchem Stoff die sind, irgendein weiches Metallmaterial, Blech, weiß ich nicht, und man schiesst darauf mit Luftdruck. Ganz einfacher, simpler Spaß. Ein ganz einfacher Spaß. Es ist so naiv und nüchtern. Genau. Ich finde es, ja, ich habe als Kind grossen Spaß daran gehabt. So, jetzt wurde das Haus, ist es nicht mehr, ist weg. Zerstampft, zermalmt. Zerstampft, zermalmt, es ist in Malmstrom gezogen worden. Ich wurde beauftragt, Dinge, die wir nicht mehr brauchen können, loszuwerden. Jetzt hatte ich dann sehr lange diese Waffe rumliegen bei mir. Sieht die denn aus wie eine echte Waffe oder ist das so eine, weil so bei so Biathlon-Schützen, da sehen die Gewehre manchmal so ein bisschen abgespaced aus. Man könnte von außen wirklich denken, du bist Stefan der schwarze Rächer, der nachts mit seiner Waffe durch die Gassen zieht. Die sieht aus wie so eine P99, die diese Polizisten haben. Also so eine No Bullshit, nichts daran sagt Sport, es sagt einfach nur, die ist auch super schwer und so Metallen. Alles daran sagt Tod, Zerstörung und American Way of, ich mach euch alle fertig, wenn ihr mein Haus einbrechen wollt. Dafür fand ich, da habe ich überlegt, die zu behalten, wenn man mal einen Brecher hat, wenn man dann diese Waffe rausholt, sagen die wahrscheinlich, okay, ich bin raus hier. Kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja, ich habe mir entschieden, die zu verkaufen, so und dann habe ich die, dann habe ich überlegt, wie mache ich es bei allen anderen Sachen, die ich verkaufe, eBay Kleinanzeigen. Ja. Und habe gedacht, ja, ich werde ja überprüfen, ob derjenige, der bei mir denn die abholt, über 18 ist. Background-Check, klar. Klar, natürlich, mein kleines Background-Check, Schufa. So und dann habe ich es reingestellt und relativ schnell kam dann die Nachricht, ihre Anzeige wurde gelöscht und sie haben jetzt einen Striket. Sie sind bescheuert, sie können auch keine fucking Waffen hier reinstellen.
Waffenhändler?
Ja, genau. Also die Überkleinzeige hat mich jetzt auf dem Zettel und hat gesagt, das ist ja sehr uncool, was die hier machen. Hätte ich drauf kommen können, ist nicht cool, sollte man nicht machen. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, das Problem, ich will die Waffe nicht mehr haben, liegt bei mir auf dem Esstisch, lag diese Waffe super lang. Sie lächelt dich quasi an.
Ich starre die an die ganze Zeit, es sieht aus wie so ein Arthausfilm. In der linken Hand, die Whisky-Glas, in der rechten Hand, die Waffe, die mittlerweile zu mir spricht. Ja, und dann gucken die so Nachbarn rein und so schockiert und ich so, nein, nein, nein, ich habe einfach einen Drink gemacht. Nein, nein, für 20 Euro, 20 Euro, 20 Euro nur ein paar mal benutzt, ach, ach, verdammt.
Dann hatte ich die da und ich wusste nicht und dann habe ich überlegt, soll ich die wegschmeissen?
Aber ich kann die ja nicht in den Müll schmeissen und dann hast du ja ein Kind, was da reinfasst und dann hast du eine Waffe in der Hand.
Also das ist, plötzlich war ich an diese Waffe gebunden.
Musst du vielleicht die Munition in einen anderen Mülleimer tun, die Waffe in einen, die Munition in einen. Ich verteile alle, die ganze Munition und die Waffe in verschiedenen Mülleimer der Stadt. Ja, oder du ballerst halt einmal die ganze Munition weg. Holst dir einfach mal eine Flasche Wodka und dann machst du mal einen Abend und verballerst einfach alle. Aber du hast jetzt kein einziges Mal mehr abgefeuert. Ja, und dann habe ich meine du sagst als kind hattest du daran spaß und so und wir haben ja jetzt a stefan ist 30 jahr der reife stefan und so aber gibt es nicht doch den kleinen jungen stefan in der sagt auch ich habe die abgefeuert so und jetzt aber ich dachte ja auch dass so eine sportpistole die kann jeder einfach kaufen. Das ist einfach nur aus Spaß. Spaß im Keller, Spaß am draussen. Spaß im Keller, der neue Roman, Stefan Tietze. So, Spaß im Keller, ne? Ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, komm, ich will es schon mal ausprobieren, weil wie toll kann das nicht schiessen, diese Dinger. Und da war auch noch diese Munition dabei. So, dann stecke ich die vorne rein, mache das Ding zu, das wird so mit Luftdruck, muss man so, ein Schuss, diese Jack Sparrow-artige Waffe, mache die zu und dann wird dadurch Luftdruck draufgeballert und dann, so, dann habe ich das, wusste ich bei meiner Wohnung jetzt nicht genau, wo ich darauf schießen soll, also habe ich so einen alten Pulli, den ich eh nicht mehr anziehe, bei mir zu Hause, so zusammengeknüllt auf die Couch gelegt und dann
aus einigen Fersen draufgeschossen.
Ja, er zieht mich endlich wieder an.
Oh, er hatte mich schon jahrelang nicht...
Moment mal, Moment mal, was ist denn da?
Ah, ah, ah, ah!
Nee, es wäre doch viel mörderischer, weil du musst ja erst mal nachladen wieder.
Stimmt, ja.
Nein, nein, nein!
Dann übergehen fünf Minuten, wo ich das so rumfummele und so zumache und dann wieder draufschiesse.
So, und dann schiesse ich aus diesem Pulli aus an die Entfernung und ich dachte ja, weil das fängt ja den Stoss ab, dieser weiche Stoff natürlicherweise, und dann habe ich dann wahrscheinlich diese Munition wieder in der Hand, wie sie aussieht. Und dann war ich einigermaßen schockiert, weil im Pulli war ein Loch. Und da habe ich gesagt, holy fucking shit, das ist ganz schön viel Wumms aus dieser Wumme. Und dann habe ich mich wieder abends mit dem Whisky da hingesetzt und dann lag wieder diese krasse Waffe auf meinem Tisch. Du musst an dieses Loch denken. Hier gegenüber sitzt der Pulli auf dem anderen Stuhl. Und ich hab nur so laut gesagt, so wie du, wo sind meine Sandalen, habe ich gesagt, wie konnte es so weit kommen. Der Pulli sass da mit dem Loch drin, tot, hing so über dem Stuhl und ich sass da mit dem Wunder. Und du so, hat dir das schon ein bisschen gefallen, so. Wie konnte es so weit kommen? Ich labte mich an seinem toten Leib, sollte es der Letzte sein, den ich tötete. Von den Machern von Wahlsturz. So, und dann habe ich gedacht, wochenlang, Wochen vergingen, hinter mir in die Sonne auf und zu, auf und zu. Die Blumen spriessen so in Riesenverschwindigkeiten. Ja, Schnee kommt, Blumen weg und so, Bäume verlieren Blätter und ich immer mit meiner Waffe da. So und dann kam mir die Idee, wahrscheinlich gibt es sowas wie Ebay ja auch für Waffen, halt irgendwie irgendwelche Gebrauchthändler oder sowas. Da habe ich so einen Sportschützenverein geschrieben, die auch welche verkaufen gebraucht, habe die gefragt, ob die meine haben wollen, wollten sie nicht, aber dann kam der zündende Hinweis, geh doch auf die Website eGun, eGun, da kannst du nämlich, so und alles an dieser Seite sieht fucking aus wie Dark Web, ich zeige es dir kurz, geh mal auf eGun.de und alles daran, alles schreit, schreit nach Dark Web. Sehr weisse Website auf jeden Fall, aber trotzdem, man fühlt sich nicht eingeladen. Egan, übersetzen hier auf Serbisch, es ist alles, es ist fantastisch. Wenn die Website sagt, sollen wir schon mal direkt auf Serbisch übersetzen? Diese Website, so und dann habe ich mich da angemeldet und ja, da muss man ein Profil. Wie ist dein Profilname? Nein, nein, nein. Wie heißt dein Profil auf Egan? Und dann ist das Lustigste. Das ist Death Collector. Ja, ich muss halt irgendeinen Namen eingeben. Und dann ist das Lustigste, ich denke mir das nicht aus. Ich bin auf Egan, melde mich an und dann muss man erst anklicken, man 18 muss ein profilnamen und so haben sie bereits getötet und dann gibt es diese sicherheitsfragen
falls man das passwort mal vergessen hatte oder sowas die kennt man ja auch von vom banking oder
sowas sicherheitsfragen und die erste auswahl die erste mögliche sicherheitsfragen die man
auswählen konnte war auf welchenchen Freund können sie am ehesten verzichten? Und das Schockierende ist, man hat sofort einen Namen im Kopf. Man hat sofort ein Gesicht mit einer Zielscheibe. Wie ist diese Frage? So fucking lustig. Und ich denke seitdem darüber nach, weil holy shit, können sie verzichten? Vor allem als ob sich das nicht ändern würde von Woche zu Woche, wenn die Idee ist ja, dass du das in einem Jahr dein Passwort vergisst und dann weisst du noch, ja Carsten, fucking Cart mich, auf welchen Freund können sie am ehesten verzichten. Und es ist ja, auf jeder anderen Website, wenn die Sparkasse Köln sagen würde, ah, sie müssen irgendwie die Frage neu ändern, hier sind die Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Und es ist nicht mehr, wie hieß ihr erstes Haustier, wie hieß ihr erstes Haustier, sondern auf welchen Freund könnten sie am ehesten verzichten, wäre ja albern. Zu der Waffen-bsite auf eine Art passend, aber es klingt so nach, wollen wir denn dann für sie, wir können denn dann für sie entsorgen. Genau, ja, welchen Freund können sie auf 160 Meter präzise zwischen die Augen treffen? Einfach mal einen Namen. Ich musste so laut lachen. Grossartig. Aber jetzt musst du natürlich schon hier im Podcast sagen, wen du da genannt hast. Nee, genau. Und dann habe ich die zweite Auswahlfrage genommen. Was ist ihre erste Waffe? Und da habe ich halt die reingeschrieben, wie ich gerade verkaufen will. Ach, ehrlich. So, und dann melde ich mich an, kriege dann ein bestätigungs-E-Mail. Alles hoch shady, alles in so HTML, wie man das kennt, wie früher die ersten Websites aussahen. Und dann hat das nicht funktioniert, ich kann mich nicht einloggen. Und dann stand da, schreiben Sie dem Webmaster. Und ich so, oh mein Gott, also warum, das ist ja ein Riesen, was für ein Sidequest-Alert gerade. Das ist einfach so ein Warlord, irgendwo im Kongo. Also schreibe ich dem Webmaster. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, was ist Ihr Geburtsdatum, muss ich mich ausweisen, und dann hat er gesagt, was ist Ihre Sicherheitsfrage und die Antwort. Und das dachte ich mir, das gibt es ja gar nicht. Nicht nur muss man ja die Sicherheitsfrage selten mal dann wieder beantworten, sondern es kam auch direkt zur Situation, er wollte eigentlich, glaube ich, nur wissen, welcher fucking Freund es sich um. Vielleicht hat einer deiner Freunde, der sich unsicher ist über die Freundschaft, diese Website geschrieben, programmiert, um zu testen, ob du ihn vor die Hunde werfen würdest, der Situation. Aber ich dachte, irre, weil ich habe sogar darüber gelacht über diesen Moment, wo man fragt, auf wenen Freunden können sie am besten verzichten. Und es ist ja wichtig, man hat einen Namen im Kopf und dann denkt man übereinander darüber nach und über die Freundschaft nach. Und plötzlich ist man diese... Ja, plötzlich so eine Abwärtsspirale und man denkt sich, habe ich überhaupt Freunde? Und jetzt ist diese Waffen-Website, wo ich eh nur so in diesen Cluster-Fak reingekommen bin, so ursächlich davon, so eine Freundschaft in Frage zu stellen. Vor allem, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man, dass die speziell für die Webseiten ausgesucht werden, zu fragen. Ich dachte, das kommt von irgendeinem Sicherheitsprogramm, dass man auf seiner Website installiert. Ich kenne nur erste Grundschullehrerin oder erste Lieblingsfilm, Haustier, Strasse, wo man geboren wurde, so allgemeine Dinge. Aber dass da jetzt man speziell auf die Inhalte der Website gepolt, diese Fragen schreibt, waren sie. Speziell auf die Website hoffe ich ja nicht, weil auf welchen Freund können sie ja jetzt? Ja gut, aber die Waffe, ich meine, das ergibt ja auf keiner anderenseiten Sinn. Aber ich lese ja auch den Webmaster mit, der es programmiert. Also wenn er, das ist die erste Frage, die oben steht. Die erste Frage, die sich ausdenkt war und man denkt so, ich stelle mir so vor, wie er so sauer war. Ich glaube, sein bester Freund hat ihm was angetan. Ich glaube auch. Und vielleicht hat er sich seine erste Waffe gekauft, weil sein Freund ihn verraten hat. Und genau diese beiden Punkte hat er dann verewigt in dieser Webseite.
Erste Frage, auf welchen Freund können Sie im ehesten verzichten?
Zweite Webseite, was ist Ihre erste Waffe?
Dann dritte Frage ist, wie viel Jahre kriegt man bei Morth?
Vierte Frage, wo würden Sie eine Leiche verscharen?
Fünfte Frage, Carsten, warum? Warum nur? Warum tust du mir was an?
Warum Jessica? Jessica war die Liebe meines Lebens.
Schlaf doch mit jeder anderen Frau.
Welche Antwort soll ich hier schreiben?
Und dann wäre es lustig, wenn man dem Webmaster so schreibt, auf welchen Frauen können sie jetzt verzichten?
Ja, Carlo. Und er sagt so, nein, falsche Antwort.
Steht hinter dir. Während du die Mail an ihn schreibst, steht hinter dir, er sagt, falsche Antwort. Oder er fragt, hä, warum Carlo? Haha, warum denn? Und dann habe ich ihm die Antwort auf meine Frage geschrieben. Die war, welches ist ihre erste Waffe? Ich habe den Modellnamen geschrieben und jetzt bin ich drin. Und jetzt habe ich sie reingestellt und es gab schon das erste Gebot. Oh, sehr gut. Ja, es ist die Waffe also bald weg. Die Waffe ist jetzt zu haben. Wie schickt man die? Man bietet da auch wie auf Ebay oder wie? Man bietet. Es ist scary. Es ist so, ich Wahnsinn, was eine komische Welt ich da kurz betreten habe. Krass. Und jetzt, ich konnte die nicht loswerden. Dann lag die bei mir rum und jetzt ist sie bald weg. Ich bin da ein bisschen froh drüber. Aber ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Bock, mir so eine zu holen. Sag das doch. Also fragst du da nicht auch im Bekanntenkreis mal rum, wer will so ein Ding? Ich habe es ein paar Leuten gezeigt. Warum hast du mir das nicht gezeigt? Du bist ja selten bei mir zu Hause. Ja, aber ich habe ja Interesse an Waffen. Also das ist doch bekannt oder nicht. Ich meine, ich besitze ein Schwert. Ja, aber ich dachte, du bist eher into Mittelalter-Kram. Ja, okay. Also wenn es eine Armbrust wäre, dann würde ich mich ärgern. Also bei Armbrust voll. Bei Armbrust würde ich komplett die das Geben sofort überlassen. Aber bei einer Schusswaffe, die so aussieht wie so eine Walter P99, boah. Und irgendwo steht jemand in seinem Wohnzimmer und sagt, wo ist meine Druckluftwaffe? Und dann klingelt es. Und dann klingelt er endlich. Und plötzlich ist sie da. Ich meine, ich habe vielleicht die Kräfte zu manifestieren. Da gibt es ja auch so Manifestieren, dass wenn du an was denkst oder was genug willst, dann passiert es auch. Vielleicht habe ich das. Und ich finde es eigentlich nur Quatsch. So spirituell bist du doch nicht. Eben. Wäre das nicht auch ein Film? So ein super rationaler wissenschaftlicher Debunk-Typ, hat dann aber so Esoterik-Fähigkeiten. Also der kann dann mit Engeln reden und er sagt, das ist alles Bullshit, esoteriker Quatsch, existiert alles nicht. Aber er kann es halt trotzdem, er kann wirklich die Zukunft vorhersagen, er kann wirklich im Kaffee-Satz wirklich fließen. Warum denkt, warum die Bank das immer noch, also warum? Ja, weil das seine Überzeugung ist. Er sagt, ich lebe in einer rationalen, wissenschaftlichen Welt. Und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, am Anfang des Films hast du dann ihn mit seiner Schwiegermutter oder so. Und die Schwiegermutter erzählt von Chakren und Chemtrails und so. Und er widerlegt das alles und so. Aber total nett, sympathischer Typ. Muss man auch bitte aufpassen. Sympathischer Typ. Und dann kriegt er aber diese Fähigkeiten. Kaffeesatz und es passiert genau so. Er kriegt sie dann erst. Vielleicht hat er sie zwei Wochen vor Beginn des Filmes schon so. Vielleicht kann man am Anfang so einen Text-Scroll machen oder so. Mal gucken. Zwei Lieder übereinander. Ich finde, wir haben zwei schöne Stimmen übereinander gesungen. Ja, finde ich auch. Am Endeffekt war es dann Star Wars. Ammonie.
Und dann hat er die Fähigkeiten, nimmt sie aber nicht an, er ringt dann damit, ob er sie einsetzt oder nicht.
Und dann hat er vielleicht so eine Situation, wo dann jemand total krank ist oder so, seine Geliebte ist total krank und er legt die Hand auf, er macht Schemling und sagt, so wie er allier, Juliel, Mariel, Arwen, Sipaliel, Fententiel, Choria. Joshua, mir geht's wieder besser. Ich weiss, ein Arzt war da, ein Arzt war da, Doktor Brönner war da. Oh, zum Glück war Doktor Brönner da. Der hilft immer.
Und da muss die Figur damit umgehen,
oh, jetzt hat sie aber diese Kräfte, die sie verneint.
Stimmt mein ganzes Leben jetzt nicht,
ich bin Wissenschaftler, Physiker vom Beruf,
muss ich das alles hinter mir lassen.
Hatte meine Schwiegermutter doch recht?
Hat sie auch diese Kräfte?
Weiß ich nicht.
Genau, haben alle Leute, die an sowas glauben
oder so ein Quote-un-Quote-Unsinn verbreiten, diese Kräfte und haben vielleicht nur die Wahl gesagt. Ja, oder nur die, die nicht daran glauben, haben die Kraft, sozusagen, dass es dann, naja. Ja, kann er irgendwie ... Dreh den mal! Dreh den doch mal! Dreh den doch mal! Dreh den und Wahlsturz, ich verstehe nicht, wieso Cast 9 in die Kinos kommt, inzwischen dann doch schon. Und nicht Wahlsturz 1. Und nicht Wahlsturz 1. Ich würde dir direkt auch die 1 geben. Wahlsturz Episode 1. Ich finde das so lustig. Stell dir mal vor so einen Indie-Arthouse-Film und dann nennt man den aber Filmtitel und dann 1, weil man so selbstbewusst denkt, ist mein Debüt, aber ich will auf jeden Fall ein Zweifel geben. Und auch direkt Römisch Eins. Römisch Eins, okay. Warum nicht Reiner? Ne, finde ich super. Vielleicht drehe ich ihn, vielleicht habe ich ja um Wochenende ein bisschen Zeit. Dreh doch mal so einen Kurzfilm. Ich finde das gut, ich finde die Idee super. Ich finde vor allem, es könnte so eine Analogie sein darüber, dass man ja gerade schon irgendwie ähm, also erstmal ist er sozusagen Esoterik und Spiritualität gefühlt dem ein bisschen zu, dann nimmt aber auch dieses Körper-Improvement immer zu und sowas und dann ist ja auch so, dass irgendwie Körper und Geist sich schon nochmal irgendwie immer mehr ein bisschen trennen, ähm, wie du, so eine Art Floating Head, du bezeichnest dich selber als Floating Head,
sagst du brauchst deinen Körper nicht mehr.
Der Cloud, ja.
Und dann sozusagen vom Körper irgendwie so Signale zu bekommen oder so,
plötzlich so spirituelle Fähigkeiten zu entwickeln,
ist natürlich für so einen Ratio-Mensch wie du,
ich glaube, es könnte eine coole Prämisse sein.
Ich bin jetzt durch Zufall auch auf YouTube
auf das Phänomen Astralreisen gestossen.
Astralreisen?
Astralreisen finde ich ganz spannend.
Und es sind Leute, die machen Astralreisen,ossen. Astralreisen? Astralreisen finde ich ganz spannend. Und es sind Leute, die machen Astralreisen. Wohin? Türkei. All-inclusive mit Strand? Ordentlich. So zwei Wochen Türkei. Die sind dann in den Astralwelten. Aber wo ist die Stadt? Naja, das ist halt einfach so eine Art Fantasy-World-Building-Welt. Nur die nehmen das ernst. Und ich glaube, was die letztendlich machen, ist sowas ähnliches wie lucides Träumen. Die haben halt gelernt, irgendwie in so einen Tag-Traum-Effekt zu kommen. Und du denkst dir eigentlich, ist ja okay so. Wollen wir ein lucides Reisebüro aufmachen? Oh, das fände ich nicht schlecht. Ja, im Grunde ist das sowas. Und da gibt es auch Bücher, die beschreiben, wie du das lernst. Und ich ich als rationaler Mensch versuche mir das zu erklären, luzides Träumen, irgendwie dann sowas in Richtung, aber die nehmen es dann halt so einen Ticken zu weit und sagen, ja, ich hab dann da im luziden Traum, hab ich dann irgendwie, wurde ich angeschossen und dann habe ich tatsächlich, meinem Körper hat sich tatsächlich eine Wunde entwickelt oder so eine Druckstelle entwickelt oder so, also das geht dann auch über vom Traum, was dann passiert und so. Und die denken halt, die sind wirklich mit ihrem Geist in irgendwelchen anderen Seinsebenen. Und haben sie psychosomatisch, haben sie dann diese Schmerzen auch. Ja, für sie ist das halt dann wirklich, manifestiert sich halt dann in unterschiedlichen Seinsebenen gedöhnt. Und da gibt es dann auch ein Video mit Comedy in der Astralebene. Also so witzige Sachen, die da passieren. So, und man stellt sich ja vor, man ist ein irgendwie unendliches Bewusstsein in Science-Räumen und die Galaxien und so. Und dann dachte ich mir, was ist denn so Comedy und so? Und letztendlich hat einer da einen Clown gesehen. So. Er hat mich jetzt auch nicht vom Hocker gerissen, wo ich sage, okay, ich gehe da jetzt irgendwie in so ein... Ich dachte mir, vielleicht gehst du in so einen Stand-Up-Club oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Es ist ein wildes Phänomen, ich bin da noch am Graben. Vielleicht sehen wir uns nächste Woche ja im Astralraum. Bist du auch mal so ein bisschen nervös, wenn du träumst und du betrittst einen Comedy-Club und denkst dir, ich kenne meinen Kopf. Da wird jetzt nichts Spektakuläres kommen. Also wenn ich im Traum in einen Comedy-Club gehe, ist das ein bisschen cringe. Aber das wäre doch saulustig, du gehst im Traum in einen Comedy-Celler und du siehst den besten Stand-Up deines Lebens und wachst auf und denkst dir, fuck, ich bin lustiger im Traum.
Genau, das passiert häufig.
Kann mich an kein Gag erinnern, nicht. Dann schreibe ich mir das alles auf und dann wache ich am nächsten Morgen auf und lese dann so Mondlandung, Schritt für die Menschheit und man denkt so, okay, ja cool, cool. Dinosaurier Flip Flops, okay, die hatten Flip Flops an oder? Neunmal im Podcast, wo die den gleichen Gag gemacht, also, phew. Pikachu, rotes Fell, aber das wird unterschiedliche Hafer haben bei Pokémon. Idee, Business-Idee. Wir nennen sie das Podcast-Ufo. Okay.
Und es ist eine Art Reisebüro für Leute, die luzid träumen können.
Ja.
Nein, es ist nicht Reisebüro, es ist so eine Kreativstütze.
Weil es gibt ja auch sehr unkreative Menschen, die über luzid träumen können.
Du musst ja aber sehr viel Fantasie haben und Kreativität, um einen spannenden, luziden Traum zu haben.
Ist nicht jeder Mensch kreativ im Unbewussten, dass man da, dass man nur durch sein Bewusstsein … Spannend, aber lass uns das mal kurz hinten anstellen, weil das ist das grösste, das grösste Nein zu dieser Prämisse, was wir haben. Aber ich bin schön, dass du das sagst und deswegen sind wir ein gutes Team. Okay, weil ich was sag und du es ignorierst. Genau, jetzt mal kurz weg. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die wahrscheinlich, wie sie träumen können, aber dann ist das, die Vorstellungsvermögen ist halt, okay, ja, ich gehe in Hamburg den Arbeitsweg lang, weil ich gehe da immer lang und nicht so, du kannst fliegen, flieg, flieg den Arbeitsweg wenigstens und dann stehe ich vor dem Pfandautomaten, aber er ging dieses Mal nicht und man denkt, er kann gehen, lass ihn wenigstens funktionieren. So, und dann weisst du, Leute, die sich träumen können, und wir geben denen sozusagen, wir machen Worldbuilding. Wir geben denen zum Beispiel Zeichnungen von unseren Angestellten, Künstlerinnen und Künstlern, wo dann so coole Welten sind und so, die dann bereisen können. Die können sich dann angucken, vorm Schlafen gehen, und wir sozusagen mit denen zusammen mit unseren Klienten, wir, Flotin und Stefan von Das Podcast UFO, schaffen es mit euch die coolsten luziden Träume. Wir erstellen euch eure Städte, wie ihr die am liebsten wollt. Wir müssen natürlich erstmal selber luzid träumen. Ich glaube, ich bin erbärmlicher Träumer, wirklich. Also jetzt in letzter Zeit tatsächlich wache ich häufiger auf nachts und dadurch habe ich auch mehr Traumerinnerungen. Und es ist absolut erbärmlich. Also es ist wirklich, ich denke, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Dann habe ich so einen Traum irgendwie, ich weiss, ich muss in Raum 307, gucke mich auch in so einem Korridor um, 307, dann sehe ich eine Tür und da steht drauf Raum 305 bis 308. Und ich denke mir, hä, muss ich da jetzt rein? Und ich wache auf. Und ich denke mir so, Gott, ey, du kannst auf dem Gipfel Himalajas stehen, du kannst Stars treffen, du kannst irgendwie durch den Vulkan schwimmen. Und ich denke mir so, Moment, eine Tür ist dann hinter dann nochmal und aufwacht. Das ist so fucking erbärmlich. Ich finde die Frage gut. Es ist so dumm einfach. Warum ist es eine Tür? Ja, warum sind drei Räumen eine Tür? Was ist da los? Brandschutz, das wäre mein erster Gedanke gewesen. Brandschutz-Fragezeichen, wach auf. Ich nehme es einfach fucking erwerblich. Man ist fast vor aufzuwachen, um aus diesem furchtbaren Aufzug. Ja, vor allem die Träume sind so kurz und es ist immer so wenig Inhalten. Ein Kumpel von mir, ein Kumpel von mir, den auf den ich am ehesten verzichten könnte, der träumt sehr David Lynch-artig und das ist halt auch nicht schön. Also guckt er sich links um und dann ist da ein Pferd, wo vorher noch die Ex-Freundin stand, aber das ist ein Pferd. Dann dreht er sich um und das Pferd fällt um und ist blutig und zertrocknet und das Blut fließt weg und dann geht er raus, aber er war auf einem Schiff und das Meer ist ein Blut. Das ist halt aber auch nicht, wie du träumen willst. Es klingt ja wahnsinnig kreativ und cool. Ja, denkst du dir cool. Und man denkt so, holy shit, ist wie eine Traumsequenz aus, wirklich so Twin Peaks oder sowas. Aber es ist ja absolut horrific, das willst du ja auch nicht, so willst du ja auch nicht träumen. Ich hätte gerne Mittelding. Okay, dann sowas wie Tür, Raum, Blut bis 307. So, guck mal, da kann man, was ist die Bedeutung dahinter? Genau. Ach, ich weiss nicht, naja, mal schauen. Ich werde versuchen, besser zu träumen und... Ich möchte, dass du die Woche besser träumst, ich möchte, dass ich meine Waffe verkaufe, ich will die endlich mal loswerden, ich komme mir vor wie so eine Better Call Saul Episode, ich will die Waffe jetzt loswerden. Und dann kaufst du davon was Friedliches und dann spendest du das, was du dann bekommst von dem Geld, für den Frieden. Genau, alles klar. Ihr könnt uns auch auf Patreon.com folgen, schlecht als Podcast. Weil wir das spenden dann. Für den Frieden. Nee, ich würde was davon machen. Das ist mein Versprechen. Ich kaufe von diesen 20 Euro, die ich dafür bekomme, etwas Friedliches. Was den Frieden steigert in der Welt. Friedstiftendes. Frieden, was Frieden stiftendes, finde ich gut.
Ihr überlegt euch bis nächste Woche mal bitte, auf welchen Freund oder Freundin ihr am Ehesten verzichten könnt.
Schreibt es in die Kommentare, schreibt es auf Reddit.
Taggt die Leute unter euch, schön auf TikTok.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Das war Flo und den Will und Stefan Tietze und wir freuen uns sehr auf die nächste Ausgabe.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben, absteigen auf, grimmeln Hebel, drehen den Hebel um. er auf die nächste Ausgabe.